look at van damme he did that on the uh
semis did you just chop his arm oh cause
he got hit with a dart the most
dangerous element is having your
director sitting on the hood of a car
everybody welcome back to stuntman react
we are back
we got eric with us today
thank you for having me you are the true
og you started this whole series eric
well guys we have a ton of fun clips
that we got to talk about today
i know nico has had a vault full of
clips just for eric
yep so let's dive right in
you guys have been asking for this for a
very long time we're finally doing it
we're breaking down
the extraction car chase for you guys
what really stood out to me is just like
what they were able to pull off with
very little
and probably how difficult it was to
film in this country
with all these moving parts
part of the way they did accomplish that
and they digitally stitch these wipes
together
so they're only locking down sections at
a time
of the road or the city they're in yeah
the blends here are
really nice and seamless and it just
keeps going like right there yeah going
into the car
the camera just went through the rear
windshield that's pretty sweet
i think that's one of the things that
takes me out of it personally i'm
not taking away from it all i think it's
fantastic but i feel like a lot of the
wipes happened where i would expect them
to happen
yeah and i can just tell that they did a
wipe there that's so that's a good point
for us when we're watching this
it's so in the foreground that it's hard
to not see it
also what really stood out more than the
stunt work
is what the camera guy was doing and i
know for a fact that that was
sam hargrave the guy who directed it the
most dangerous element
without a doubt is having your director
sitting on the hood of a car
holding how much does a camera like that
one like 15 pounds yeah 20 pounds
you have him harnessed in so every time
it stops he's like
there's a couple of places where he is
about to hit the car
in front of him and he like lifts his
legs although they don't tap
yeah when that car does the reverse 180
you can see it like sweep right by his
legs
right here
driving right there decision but he
started off as uh captain america
i believe it was winter soldier but he
was the main stunt double for chris
evans in that movie he then went on to
stunt coordinate avengers so then when
it came to avengers in game
he was helping second unit direct so you
can just see how this guy is able to
keep expanding his talent into
filmmaking not just physically but
behind the camera
and then from that you know he really
like kind of bonded with the
russo brothers and they obviously loved
this guy the russo brothers were able to
like pick out this talent and just not
think of
him as some dumb stunt guy to the point
that they were like why don't you direct
this movie for us
from a producer standpoint in a general
sense of things
he had zero business directing this
movie however the russo brothers had
spent so much time getting to know him
and seeing his work firsthand that
they're like this is the guy that we
should put our chips in the middle and
bet on
and i think it really paid off
so congratulations sam you have ascended
to mount
olympus
so eric you are the master of fire
stunts at least you've been the master
of fire since you come into here and
talk to us we haven't really had anybody
else that does as much pyro as you
so this is a clip from an old film
called the thing from another world and
there's some pretty gnarly fire stuff i
want you to take a look at it and just
tell me what you think
one point line the needle's at the top
whoa wow terrifying
damn they keep going like just keep
throwing fuel on them the thing that
really stood out to me was the fact that
throwing
liquid buckets of fuel on the guy which
just seems so uncontrolled
relatively speaking the fire kind of
goes out quickly
and it doesn't really stick to them a
lot lighting clint on fire we're using
like a
rubber cement based fuel so it sticks
the glue doesn't burn it's the fumes
coming off of it that burn
this i'm gonna guess that they are
throwing alcohol
on them and not gasoline that's why
it kind of hits the ground it splashes
it burns and then it's gone
where gasoline would probably stay a
little bit more
so it makes me think it's alcohol which
is super dangerous honestly
because it just burns at such a very
incredibly hot rate that's why it's like
burning and gone same with doing
gasoline it burns very hot as well
that's old school and like kind of the
way they had to do it back then
that guy obviously he's got a full head
mask on
i bet he has three layers of nomex on
and then
also he's got like a fireproof racing
suit
over top of that completely soaked in
gel he's probably freezing
and then i'm gonna go with a probably
put them on oxygen
it seems risky to have an oxygen tank i
guess the whole burning part too is
risky
do they have to switch out his
protective layers for every shot that
they do here
they would they would take him
completely apart and put them back
together and the reason is because you
just burn down
set you're gonna reset that too and you
can't have them sitting around
and they're freezing you know there's
one little thing that happens on the
side here that catches my eye
the guy that's holding up the mattress
so he's still there holding the mattress
bouncing around
[Music]
run out of there now is there really a
dude back there
just like a rope stick through the set
just like yeah
like that's such a ridiculous detail why
no there's no way they did that i think
there's a grip with a pole through the
wall like kind of moving it up and down
just to make sure it's like he's still
there
another thing too the second bucket
right there boom he comes at him and
he's touching fire you know i kind of
showed you
it's like if something's on fire you can
kind of like run your hand through it
okay
and as long as you keep moving and then
you're back out of it you like feel the
heat and then
it's it's okay he seemed to move on
pretty quickly those guys were certainly
getting hot in there don't give props to
the cinematography here too they turn
off the lights before it comes in so the
fire illuminates the room
and the exposure is actually really
dialed in so like you can see the detail
in the flames
hey guys a lot of these clips that we
see in the show are inspired from the
things that you found so i have a
request for you for stunts here
please leave a suggestion down below of
the coolest stunt from a foreign film
that you have seen that way we can look
for some clips here that might be
unseen by a lot of our audience and shed
some light on how they're made
no retreat no surrender you know nothing
about this i don't know anything about
this
there's this guy who is training in
martial arts his dad is a karate
instructor
van damme makes one of his first
appearances in this movie as a villain
vandan comes like shut down their karate
school kicks the crap out of the dude's
dad
and then knocks him on his butt so very
discouraged
his father's like it's over and he like
tears his bruce lee poster in half
he takes off running down the street and
ends up stumbling upon
a abandoned house and then out of
nowhere bruce lee's spirit
comes to him and
essentially starts training this oh my
god to be able to beat van damme
yes it's 80s don't full contact karate
the world's deadliest game is being
kicked apart by the second
look at van damme he did that on the uh
semis yeah
three whip kicks in a row right to the
face
you're good i get better
well the gloves are coming off the
shirt's coming off yes
he's behind you dude do you look up
behind you
that didn't even hit him
[Laughter]
dude it's just like wrestling
wow he's sick do you see how he kicked
him too look at this he kicked him like
this he went
like an inside crescent cave and look at
how he was flying he's like
pretty solid fall though yeah that was
really good
dude
turned into a wwe
[Music]
damn
good stuff pretty cool i can be really
psyched on this if i was like
10 years old hey if you like this show
and you'd like to keep watching it
please consider subscribing it actually
helps us out helps the audience watch
this video and it helps youtube know
that people enjoy it and recommends it
to more people so
yeah consider subscribing if you're not
we'd really appreciate it thank you did
you guys watch the old guard
no no okay
i think a lot of these fight scenes in
here it's not like there's something
egregiously bad
there's just kind of nothing that
special about it
charlize theron is a savage from doing
atomic blonde you know mad max so she
clearly looks good
and knows what to do some of her
counterparts not so great
[Music]
this other girl hasn't had as much
training for sure
[Music]
and i mean this camera work is doing the
best it can to make them
look really good that's what you do as a
director when you may have somebody
that's not as strong as finding somebody
else has a lot more experience
is you do some edits to make that stuff
work and make them both look good
we're done i think the biggest thing for
me with action movies
now everything feels so cliche and i'll
watch the trailer for something i'm like
i don't care
i've seen this movie a million times
yeah you know and that's what i felt
when i saw the old guard trailer i was
like i don't care about this
at all you know like i need something
fresh so i feel like the old guard
is a rip-off of that anime wait what is
this right here this isn't this is the
old guard what is this
i thought you guys being anime nerds
would own this i was literally watching
anime last night and you still
out-nerded me man yeah eric
so the old guard is i think a rip-off
of this anime which is fantastic it's on
netflix
you should definitely check it out if
you're into anime basically these are
people that cannot die
they're trying to put them to sleep
because they can't die they always come
back from the dead no matter what
happens so he gets hit with a tranq dart
he then
chops his own arm off so he can keep
fighting like literally puts his arm
against the wall to chop it off so the
blood splatters on the wall
and then as they hit him with tranq
darts he knows he's gonna pass out and
be captured
so he puts a gun to his head and kills
himself so that he's dead
and then he regenerates comes back and
keeps kicking butt
that's essentially what happens in the
old guard
except for not nearly as good yeah this
looks awesome i love how it makes it
sick if only we had an animator's react
episode we could talk about
stuff like anime wait a minute and you
can find it on this channel you can go
look for it
dude eric that was awesome man it is
always a pleasure having you
on the show i always learn a whole lot
when you come on and we always take a
look at like really sick clips that you
don't normally see every day so
thank you so much for coming down all
the way from atlanta yeah absolutely
thanks for having me
thank you if you guys want to see more
of eric's stuff or send him questions
whatever you can follow him on instagram
at
eric linden or you can go to his website
that's correct but eric thanks again for
coming on dude i freaking love you man
it's so good to see you
yeah good to see you guys